hello and welcome to GameSpot's last of
us part two spoiler chat a lot of us
have been waiting for this there's a lot
to talk about with this game joining me
today is the reviewer Callie Peggy Oh
Edmund Tran hello and Jordan remai hello
so we've all played the last of us now
some of us multiple times but Callie why
don't you start since you reviewed it
what are your overall thoughts on the
Last of Us part two yeah first of all I
just want to say I have two reviews one
of which has no spoilers and the other
one is a spoiler review if you're
listening to this podcast I assume that
you could handle the spoiler review I
encourage you to check that out there's
they're the same review same score the
spoiler one is just more detailed and
with more you know with spoilers I can
talk a little bit more about why I
thought the things that I thought about
this game so please read that my overall
takeaway is that I think this game is a
fantastic character study I really
particularly fell in love with Abbey as
a character I think the game doesn't
work without her and her section really
was a pivotal moment role not moment but
a pivotal part for me in in really
appreciating this game I do think that
you know if we examine violence in the
Last of Us part two as a mechanic I
think that's where the game has some
issues I know that well we'll get into
some of the other issues that other
people had with the game but for me that
was the the big stumbling block was the
the use of violence in certain instances
being pretty unexamined you know neither
Ellie nor a be really faces consequences
for the they're not nameless but the
largely nameless largely anonymous grunt
type characters that you kill in the
game however overall I thought that the
story was really something and it really
affected me a lot
and yeah so overall I liked it
how about you ed yeah affected me a lot
is a good way to put it I upon finishing
game upon finishing this game I was kind
of left into like a bunk
a few days afterwards it's a very bleak
and very hopeless game there are some
moments of Liberty in there that you do
forget about and you do appreciate in
new ways once you come around the second
time which I did but I think overall it
was a very powerful game for me I do
recognize it has its faults for sure but
it is very effective in a lot of
different ways and not just because
there's been a lot of money thrown at it
I think the character study thing is you
know a very strong point and ABI is one
of the best parts of the game which was
just it's such a shame that we can talk
about her at all for a long time the
overall a very effective effective game
yeah I mean I know we don't typically
talk about you know how much money was
spent on a game but there are a lot of
risky decisions in this game considering
how much money Sony threw at it and
Naughty Dog but Jordan how about you
were your overall thoughts pretty much
echoing a lot of the stuff that Callie
and Ed said very affecting very bleak
game thank God for the few moments of
Hope because I don't think I would have
gotten through the game without them uh
also thank God for a because there was
definitely a point around like day three
of Le section where I was like I don't
know if I like this game and ABI really
saves it for me in the latter half I
have a few qualms with the game play
mainly and how it can sometimes cause
the pacing to kind of get a little
strange near the end of the game it can
kind of make some parts that I kind of
wanted to get to the next cutscene and I
spent a lot of time doing certain things
that the game plan kind of demanded that
I do I wish those issues had kind of
been addressed but overall I came away
from it with a mostly positive
impression of the game yeah I mean I
echo you guys for the most part like I
agree overall I really enjoyed it I have
some issues with how its structured in
the pacing but the more I think about it
the more that the structure of this game
is very important to the story it tells
I just think that
this the way it's structured doesn't
seem as confident as the first game and
I think overall I think almost every
aspect apart from the gameplay itself I
think the first game does better like
the characters the story the way it's
structured the the settings for the most
part all that stuff I definitely prefer
in the first game which to be fair you
know the Last of Us one is probably one
of my favorite games of all time so I
wasn't going into this game expecting it
to top it but I overall I'm very happy I
played this and one thing that I do want
to mention is that this game like it a
sequel definitely makes sense which I
know is something that a lot of people
question before the game came out
whether or not last was needed a sequel
or if it was just a good enough story by
itself but I think that this last was
part two definitely earns its its role
as a sequel its position as a sequel I
guess however you want to say it but
yeah overall I really enjoyed it and it
sounds like we all enjoyed it for the
most part but why don't we get more into
the story here and let's start with the
first big story beat which kind of sets
everything in motion which tore my heart
out at the time being such a fan of the
first game but it is Joel's death which
happens almost right away and I think a
lot of people watching this may have
known this before the game actually came
out because it was one of the many
things that was leaked how did that make
you all feel I mean you're talking about
like how this sequel feels necessary and
you know Joel's death is a big reason
for that it's you know how do you get
away with the [ __ ] that you did in the
first game without any consequences and
this whole game is about the
consequences of your actions and so
Joel's death is obviously a very big
thing that happens a very gruesome thing
that happens something that really shook
me to my core
especially in just how gorya was and
yeah it's it it I it sets Ellie on her
quest for revenge which at times you
can't 100% agree with because of the
dangers and
the all that she has to lose but I I get
what I did it I get what I did it how
about you guys I I wrote about the tonal
whiplash in my spoiler review because
like the scene before that is or like
pretty close to Joel actually being
beaten to death is Ellie and Dena like
getting it on in a basement it's like
this play weed they're smoking weed you
hear about smash Brandy's couch or
whatever like which I missed my first
playthrough I only saw the porn parodies
my second playthrough because I was
being a little bit more thorough in the
beginning of the game and I was like
okay that's you know that really doesn't
fit with the rest of the game and I
think this is one of the last moments of
like respite before you get in to I mean
it's the last good thing that happens
before Joel dies but it's also one of
the last good things that happens in the
whole game not many of the things that
happened are good and so I was still
reeling from that I was like yeah yeah
Dena like you guys have been flirting
forever let's go and then Joel died and
I was just like not even I don't think I
fully like registered it um
right away I was kind of like oh that's
well that's certainly happening in front
of me and so when I played it the second
time it had more emotional weight
because I was a little more prepared for
it even though I knew it was gonna
happen which maybe sounds weird but it
is a really emotional scene and watching
Ellie struggle so much to try to save
him is really painful and I say my heart
bleeds more so for Ellie than Joel in
that moment like I I am sad for Joel I
don't really want him to die so much
because I do like his character from the
first game but I can also understand
where Abby and her friends are coming
from like he just he kills a lot of
people at the end of the first game like
you kind of had it coming but I'm really
sad that Ellie has to watch you go
through this it wouldn't have been
better if she like hadn't been there but
the fact that she has to watch you get
beaten to death is heart-wrenching for
me personally and I have to admit like
the entire build-up to that scene where
you're switching back and forth between
Ellie and Abbie and you can just see
their paths beginning to converge and
you know something is going to happen
like when all the players meet together
and I'm like well something Bad's going
to happen because something bad has
happened at beginning of every revenge
story and I don't know who's going to
die what's going to happen there's a
bunch of people that I want to make out
of this and I don't know who it's going
to be I think not a dog does a really
good job of flashing between characters
enough times that you're led all the way
up to that moment not entirely sure like
who's going to die or be injured in some
capacity addition in that opening
structure is really really good yeah and
like the way it bounces between
characters like you're saying I thought
was super successful in that like I you
know something bad like I just had a pit
in my stomach playing that entire time
because I was like someone's gonna die
and I think it's gonna be Joel like it
couldn't be Dena like I don't think I
don't think this story would have worked
as well if it was Dina who got the bad
wait yes there's a part of you that
fears that maybe it's a possibility yeah
and and um I think we've talked about
this before like the marketing for this
game was intentionally misleading and I
think one of the earlier trailers made
it seem like Dena was the one that was
gonna die so that's kind of where my
head was at when I was playing that too
so it was kind of a relief like I was uh
Oh Dina's safe but also that's not I
don't want him to die either and like I
like you're right Jordan because you're
like it could be Tommy
it could be Jesse it could be all they
introduce a lot of different people that
are close to Ellie and you don't fully
understand the nature of their
relationships and that opening but you
see a lot of them and you know that they
have these existing relationships so the
the question of it of who is gonna get
got is definitely
a big one nicer so what our yes sir
obvious in retrospect I know it's so
funny because there's a new story that
just came out about Sunnis marketing if
spider-man Maz Morales and they said
they don't intentionally mean to be
misleading which they totally did with a
lawsuit demoed it back in August or
whenever that that section in the
suburbs in Hillcrest I think when you
get to the end and you know how Jesse
normally reaches in grabs Elly and pulls
her in and says like I wouldn't let you
do this alone when I who and I played
that game it was Joel and originally I
think I thought Jill was gonna die
because the the original trailer they
released like Joel's presence in it felt
really weird like the way he was like I
don't know walks into this house kind of
ghostly and he's like I'm gonna kill
every last one like a lot of people were
like Joel's dead but then after I played
it after I played the demo I was like
Nigel survives it's fine like it's not
him thank God but then like you're
saying I'd like the more you think about
it like this story wouldn't have worked
if it was anyone else at least as a
revenge story because like if Tommy died
I'd be like that sucks I mean no I think
it's so funny it they like rendered and
acted a whole scene for the demo that
you played Jake just to throw you off
the scent what happens you got that Sony
money I guess so moving along Joel's
death kind of sets off this revenge
quest for Elia and she heads to Seattle
with Dina now this is one of the things
that I remember you saying you had
trouble with both in your review and in
the first time we recorded this but we
had to scrap that one was how you almost
didn't really want to go along on this
journey with Ellie Kelly do you want to
expand on that a little bit yeah I um
you know I like Jordan said Joel kind of
had it coming obviously it's not
pleasant to watch him die and it's it's
sad it is it's hard having the history
that we all have with that game in the
history that Ellie has with Joel as a
character but it's
not surprising to me that someone would
want to hunt him down and kill him
brutally given what he did and I was
kind of like what if we just didn't what
if we just what if we just stayed in
Jackson Jackson is idyllic it is like
this pastoral ideal to me like I want to
go live in a farmhouse I like I love but
it's just like we all do have our job
that we do and we have dances and movie
nights and it's like a nice little the
best you could hope for after an
outbreak like that has happened in this
world so and she's a new girlfriend so
I'm like you has so much here and you
and we learn eventually that led s full
scope of what Joel did and the truth
about her immunity and the surgery and
it's like you know this and you know
that this is just gonna be a cycle like
a vicious cycle of violence what if you
just didn't go and so I threw Ellie's
section I increasingly was like God do
we have to like I just wanted to be like
just go to therapy please it's gonna
like just deal with your grief like a
normal person I know you're not a normal
person because you were born into it
puck ellipse but like yeah I struggled
not in like a it doesn't make me don't
want to play the game or anything I just
it was a conflict that I had while
playing and I do think that it's
effective because I don't think you're
supposed to necessarily want to go to
the lengths that Ellie's going um I
think Edie brought this F when we
recorded the previous version of this so
I'll let ed talk about it but Deena is a
huge reason why you want to turn back
oh yeah it's it's is it because she's
pregnant and all that I don't wanna
steal your point from you I've got a
point that I made eyes at a bet yeah
well she's pregnant and sick like she's
really sick and that's the point where
most people would be like okay okay you
know what let's just pack it in well
yeah Deena is like kind of the better
version of Ellie because there's a bit
of dialogue when you you
downtown Seattle Wed Regina's like oh
man if I you know could find my sisters
killers I'd probably torture them that
you know she doesn't you know she she
keeps it all inside she keeps it
together and even though she has her and
[ __ ] going on she's looking at brothers
I guess and she's you know just being a
generally good person and she knows her
endgame I you know is just to live a
good life you know bombers at the end
where Elian dinner of raising JJ you
know she is still dealing with all the
trauma from their adventure as well you
know freaking Jessie got shot in the
face like it was you know Tuesday or
whatever but she has her own way of
dealing things which is a lot more
realistic than Ellie but you also
brought up a good point last time about
you know Ellie being immune and she has
this thing where she you know she had a
greater purpose and she lost that and
you know what does that mean for her
sense about what her life means and what
life is all about yeah we should clarify
that there were audio issues with the
previous recording and that's my word
again it is not a big deal but yeah I
think like Jordan had brought us sorry
we keep doing this Jordan brought up the
really good point of like yeah he
doesn't really seem realistic and to
that point I was talking about how like
for a normal person yes but Ellie does
have the knowledge that she's immune and
in a flashback you see her going into a
place with Joel that has spores and he's
like masks on and she's like why what's
the point of that because she's like 15
or whatever so every 15 year-olds like
but why though and he's like what if
someone sees you and she's kind of
flippant because she knows it can't hurt
her so I do think there's an element of
that in how far Ellie goes with things
how intensely she fights I think she
just has a little bit of an
invincibility thing going on because
like there's a lot in this world that
can't kill her so when I when I fully
wrap my mind around that I came to grips
a little bit more with her kind of
ruthless unrelenting desire for revenge
because it's just like what does she
have left
and also you know you find out that the
last conversation she and Joel had was
about working towards forgiveness and I
it's a reference that is it like the
very end of the game one of the very
last scenes but I yeah I know I'm we're
jumping around a little bit but this is
all in service of talking about this
like struggle I had with Ellie kind of
but you find out that like that was the
last conversation they had and so it
took me a couple days after playing that
came to really wrap my head around that
but um I think that it was more about
finding her forgiveness than revenge for
Allie is what I came away with it like
that was more her processing the events
of the last four plus years of her life
so yes it was about revenge but it was
also about like like I kind of got the
sense like I have to get revenge for
Joel because that's the only way that I
can forgive him for what he did yeah and
that's a lot harder to pick up on in the
first first time because some of the
issues we have around the structure of
the game like so much information is
withheld from you they you just have to
go along with this ridiculous notion
that Ellie has to travel across the
country and kill a million people just
just cause she got you know her dad died
you have a lot more context and you're
much more willing to go along and see
her internal struggles as well as her
rampage yeah that context helps in the
second place and I think my biggest
problem with the first playthrough is
you get like in a lot of revenge stories
like Hamlet and Assassin's Creed 2 like
a moment where like the hero has gone
like so far that the story needs to
provide an almost rational reason for
why they decided to keep going is like
Oh a motion is no longer driven then
they also have like oh here's another
reason why I'm doing this little better
like some people around me and then the
audience is like okay I still don't
completely agree with your emotional
response but you provided me another
reason that I can kind of get on board
with and the Last of Us part two kind of
leaves that explanation for you to the
very end so for the entire
la portion the first time I'm playing
I'm like I don't like any of this you're
not providing me any reason for why I
should get on board with Ellie's quest
of in the fact that I should feel
furious that they killed Joel and even
though I am sad that they killed Joel
I'm not angry that they killed Joel I'm
sorry I've been trying to talk for a
while I had a slightly different
experience though because I was like
totally on board with doing this revenge
story right when they killed Joel
because like I said it's such a big fan
of the first game I thought Joe was a
fantastic character and when they killed
him I think I stayed up till like 3:00
a.m. because I was like yeah I'm with
you Ellie like I know Jackson's cool but
I want to get out of here and I want to
hunt down every single one of these
people including ABI who I like freakin
hated at the time like I really felt
that anger and I definitely gets to a
point I think like after after Ellie
kills Norah
it got a hit a point where I was like
alright maybe we're taking this a little
too far like at least girlfriends know
Dina's sick and pregnant like Jessie's
not doing well he went he came all this
way just for this and I was like I think
it's time to stop now but that's when I
started to feel how you felt where this
game was just like nope just cuz you're
done doesn't mean Ellie's done because
Ellie has a lot more work to do I just
wanted to say I wasn't laughing what you
said Jordan's I totally agree I just
loved that you listed both Hamlet and
Assassin's Creed 2 I was scrambling for
like examples of revenge stories and
like Hamlet's like the go-to literally
when I'm like I should come up with an
actual yeah I I do think like Jake when
was the last time you played the
original last of us because it has been
since launch for me so I played a year
ago and I've also played the original
asters probably half a dozen times like
on multiple difficulties like I've said
it before on GameSpot after dark and
whatnot but like that game is why I
wanted to write about video games and
make videos about video games is because
that game had such a profound impact on
me yeah so I think that like given your
history it makes a lot more sense that
that you bought into it and I mean the
interesting like the cool thing about it
is I think we've all after some time
with this game we've all approached the
same conclusion about it
near nearly we have varying issues and
varying interpretations but like even
with without that attachment that jake
has like I still came around like I
fully understood the context of that
revenge when all was said and done so I
think that is a strength of the story
ultimately once it's over despite some
of the storytelling issues and
especially upon starting a second
playthrough and you have more that
context it definitely sweeps you up the
first time it is very much dr. Mela is
off the chain and it's the drama is
really engrossing so it's it it makes
it's very easy to lose your [ __ ] as I do
many times like when Joel got killed and
when they made you play Abbey I was
furious but you know in retrospect it's
yeah it's interesting that we all come
to the similar feeling about it
yeah and before we move on to Abbey I do
want to talk about some of the
flashbacks because you're saying like
one of the few good parts in this are
happy sections is early on but there are
a couple more but their flashbacks and
the one that I that stands out most is
when they go to the museum when Joel
takes the museum which like all the
flashbacks I thought were great little
vignette scenes and it made me wish like
I've kind of wish like there was a
direct sequel to yeah I want to play
more of those in between yeah I I just
finished a playthrough remastered and
left behind before my second playthrough
the game so I finished that first finish
last but spot to first then went back
from the start and it's it was such a
bummer to see that young playful
innocent jovial Ellie making puns in
there like my stuff go away into so
suddenly and it is super nice to go back
to that and remember that oh she did
to be really cool to be around she you
know beam of positivity and you know
radiant energy and she's so good this is
bit I don't know if you guys went to the
bathroom of the museum where you can
just like pull faces yeah it's so good
she's just she can make it do this
cheesy grin and it's just it's just
completely from person it's it makes it
makes it all more sad I guess yeah
that's no sorry you know go ahead I was
gonna say something stupid I just gonna
say like that's that's the effective
that's that's Joel's impact on her right
like like Joel kind of enabled both
sides of Ellie like bringing her to the
museum is is him bringing out that good
side but like his actions are have
directly resulted in the the dark Ellie
that we see in part two but I I wanted
to say that I was describing the museum
scene to my dad yesterday and I almost
started crying because it did remind me
of like kuzzik telling him about like
the space stuff and how he worked really
hard to get a recording of the moon
landing or whatever and like I was just
talking about that that's very much the
dynamic I had with my dad and I was you
know an early teenager so I was like oh
no I've been bottling up these emotions
and they're coming out and I mean I was
just gonna say that another like great
little I don't know optional thing you
can do in that museum scene is you you
can put up put a hat on as Ellie but if
you find another hat you can Ellie will
make Joel wear it and he'll be like I'm
not wearing a hat and you can like keep
pressing him and eventually he'll wear
the hat and I just really liked that
scene it kind of goes back to what you
were saying like even though Joel did
all these terrible things he also did
kind of foster that that happier side of
Ellie which kinda disappears when he
dies I don't have to shout out my
favorite scene when she sits in the
office chair it says oh hello no one the
dinosaurs are busy right now oh it is
one
it's crazy that all that is is optional
you can miss all of that it's yeah I
mean suite optional stuff too something
we kind of skipped this the scene in
Seattle at the Music Store in downtown
where I mean it's tough to miss and we
talked about a little bit last time was
how well designed these levels are and
that especially that open area and that
it like does a very good job of making
sure you go to all the points of
interest but that spot in particular
Ellie plays guitar and she plays a
little bit of the Pearl Jam song but
stops and ends up playing take on me
which I thought was like another great
scene which you know some people might
miss yeah and that's another thing that
Joel imparted to Ellie is a guitar
playing which will we'll talk about
market to the end but I do want to talk
about this is kind of what I was
alluding to and I might like the last
bits of happiness and a rest of it and I
think that open area when you're in
downtown Seattle is really the it's it
is a moment of respite there's a lot to
explore there's no human enemies
you just get to kind of get to know
Deana more like talking to Dina in the
synagogue about her family
I loved exploring that Bank where there
they were robbing the bank on outbreak
day because they're dumb there's just a
lot of good in that open area and and I
really do wish that there was a little
bit more of that because I think the
rest that there are somewhat open areas
like that but not nearly to that level
and it is really an accomplishment how
the game kind of organically leads you
through the map interface from point of
interest to point of interest so so good
at that
yeah just like that up just like the
Dayton lost legacy like that open area
was in my light and then game to its I
think it must take a lot of work because
they should have known more of them but
they didn't mm-hmm sorry Jordan oh no I
was just saying like it's basically a
date the game gives you an opportunity
to if you want to as quickly as possible
just kind of speed through that area but
you over time just you talking to Dina
and you're like I want to hear more and
if I want to hear more and then
I do more exploring to like get more
conversations - sorry it's like a really
clever way of giving you to want to care
about a person and ask them about who
they are and learn about them and make
you care about them and when I first
played it I was very worried I'm like
this is leading to Dina somehow someway
being killed later in the game because
they want me to care about her which I'm
very happy that they didn't go back and
do it but I thought it was a really nice
way of making you care about this new
character where they're like look we
advertise that this was gonna be another
Ellie Joel story Joel's gone Ellie now
has this new partner we're gonna give
you a chance to fall in love with her
before just jumping straight into like
the main gritty aspect of this story
yeah
pregnancy true horror you gotta have a
date before the pregnancy card comes out
yeah I love that line which it says
don't worry it's not yours okay we're
moving on to probably the big pivotal
moment in this game when the game kind
of switches protagonists on you then now
you've you've already played his a be up
till this point a couple times but
basically right when Abby knocks on the
door of the movie theater shoots Jesse
in the head very unceremoniously you
know he runs out the door he is so much
better I know that's like it that's just
the end of his character and then Tommy
gets wounded but then before Ellie and
Abby face off we get a three day detour
from from Abby's perspective and what
she's been doing while Ellie's been on
this revenge quest what'd you guys think
of this section I know based on early
conversations everyone really liked this
but I know
Edie and I particularly had some mixed
feelings and we started playing his Abby
yeah it was late at night Abby had just
killed Jesse my favorite cast and then
it switched to the the flashback of her
at the park where she you know discovers
that her dad got shot in the face by
Joel which I was
like okay I I get it I see what you're
doing here and then it switches back to
present day and you stop playing as a B
and then you start picking up pills as
her and I was so pissed I was so I'm
still reeling from the anger and I guess
that's what they want you to feel like
they want you to have to have to dwell
in Abby's mind for you know as long as
you do Ellie but I you know I blog
obviously I love that bit and I think
it's one of the strongest parts of the
game but Ben I can't forget how angry
made me feel and it was very effective
in that sense they got me they got me
yeah I mean I felt the same way when
when that switch happened I was like oh
no this is gonna be three days her I
don't care what she did like I'm still
gonna hate her like she killed role but
exact you know like you I got got to and
eventually came around on her and then
not only that like replaying it I've
replayed it almost three times now and
it's definitely my favorite part of a
game like that section I think is the
strongest part of the game and Cal you
touched on your review saying that like
Abby's section is what ties this game
together without that this game would
have been very different yeah absolutely
I I will say I kind of had the same not
like oh I'm gonna hate a B but when I
realized that I had a whole new set of
skill trees and all of my weapons were
unupgraded and I didn't have any scopes
or anything else god damn it so that
that does it's a little bit of a hitch
when you get there I think Phil horn
Sean message mean he's like do I really
have to play this whole game again as a
bee
and I was like you'll see but because I
was a little bit ahead of him but yeah I
do think that I mean you the thing about
a bee section is there's a lot you don't
know about her you don't know why she's
done what she's done yet you haven't
eaten clean but you don't know exactly
why um you don't know anything about her
relationships
besides like at the beginning she has
this weird interaction with Owen and
where she's like are you breaking up
with Mel and he was like he said no and
then like said something about like like
wanting like oh do you still want some
summer something like he doesn't say
that but he says something like that
she's like no I've had my fill and I was
like what is the history there oh my god
the intrigue so I was curious to know
more about that their relationship in
particular and you have that added
tension of knowing that in theory day is
pretty much everybody she cares about
will be dead and so I thought that was
really interesting and I found that I
generally really liked storytelling
where I know certain things that are
gonna happen and there's you know the
dramatic irony of it
speaking of Shakespeare but um I yeah so
I think that was really interesting I
mean it basically starts you off by
making you play fetch with a dog you
kill a Zelly
and I was like I thought at first I was
like this is a bit much okay like I bear
is innocent in all of this but um you
know you like oh and I was dread and
knowing Owen was gonna die I was so
upset because you see the depth of their
connection and I was like oh like I
don't want you to I wish I wish I could
stop this from happening okay I wish
that I had some control maybe it's me
liking RPGs and liking character joy or
a player choice but I was just like I
wish I could prevent Ellie from killing
Owen and his pregnant girlfriend but I
can't so I thought that made the things
we do learn about Abbey in addition to
all the things we know about Abbey
really a fascinating it's a bold choice
to basically start you over from the
beginning of a brand new game halfway
through a game like it takes I want to
say 10 to 12 hours like to get to that
point which is almost the length of the
very first last of us so it feels like
you're getting to the end and then all
of a sudden the games like oh no like
you've got to go through that again from
the other side and it's like Jake said
it's a little frustrating to start over
right from the beginning all
over again but I mean she comes around
on me on me a B is a B saves this game
for me if this had just been le story
all the way through I I would not like
this game and even with the stuff that
we learn about Elly at the very end I
still would not have liked this game
it's a B's foil and her growth that
saves this game for me yeah it's not
just about humanizing all the crap that
Elly does it's just a B is just such a
great complexity nuance character like
like especially coming off of Elly who's
just like kill kill kill gotta gotta
avenge all screw data whatever she's a
burden to my side and just seeing you
know Abby's new wants relationship with
Owen which is something I've never seen
a triple AAA game before I I'm really
glad they did it you know it's it's
crazy it's crazy
who could have expected that not me
spoilers they probably expected but they
got a lot wrong about a B that's true my
understanding is correct
good um but like one thing I do want to
add one of my favorite scenes is when
Abby meets Owen in his boat and she's
telling him to grow up and he says he
says how do I grow up Abby do I just
hunt down the people who killed my
family and kill them and I thought that
was such a I don't know if I'd say like
a profound line but like for me it just
hit me I was like oh yeah what Ellie's
going through literally everyone in this
world probably has had to deal with
Athena included right but Ellie is Ellie
and Abby are the only two people at
least in this story that are going
through these lengths lengths just to
kill people and just to like get this I
don't know just to fulfill their revenge
fantasy or whatever and and I think
that's also a huge turning point for
Abby to because the slightly before that
you meet Levin Yara who are two Sara
fights who save Abby and originally she
helps them and leaves and just like it's
not my problem you guys can deal with it
but I think after that conversation
that's
really what kind of like changes
something in her or she's like alright
I'm gonna go back and I'm gonna help
these people and like from that point on
is when I was like totally sold on a B
story I was like alright I'm Way more
invested in this than then at least
entire half for the most part yeah and
yeah I I just I think it's so
interesting like somebody pointed out I
forget who it was maybe it was Evan um
that Ellie's day one or like when you
start the game that's not her to Seattle
day one it's like right before she's
going on the Patrol it starts with Jesse
waking her up and Abby's day one starts
with her being woken up by somebody and
there are so many they might even seem a
little too obvious so many like literary
foil aspects to Abby's character but the
interesting thing about the way it's
done is that Abby is further along in
her journey than Ellie so Abby's already
gotten her revenge so what we're seeing
on Ellie's side is Abby's journey before
it happened right before Joel died and
what we see with Abby is what could
happen to Ellie after like here's what a
redemption path looks like for both of
these women and we're getting that
through Abby's perspective and we don't
know if Ellie will make those kinds of
choices when we get to see them through
Abby and I thought that was really well
done that push and pull there um yeah
yeah I mean in that you know that cycle
of violence continues though after Ellie
kills all of Abby's friends then Abby
shows up and kills one of Ellie's
friends and then you have this I found
it a very difficult to seem to play
where you're playing is a be trying to
kill Ellie but before we get to that
actually I do want to talk about this
Resident Evil boss because I remember we
did talk a lot about that before and
something I do want to talk about
because I remember Jordan brought it up
last time and I think all of us kind of
liked it but that boss was out of place
and did not need to be there like I
think it creepy I think that whole
Hospital like set up is like this really
creepy has this great tone and setting
where's like you're going into this
place where you should not go like this
is a Ground Zero moment all the oldest
infected are here so at the very minimum
there are just a bunch of clickers and
there's probably worse and then they
just kind of dropped this weird action
scene at the very end of it it just
feels like such a strange tonal shift
that I'm not yet quite sure what Naughty
Dog was going for in that moment I just
know I really didn't like it I mean
obviously a tabby is incredibly buff
she's very capable place completely
different to Joel and I and I guess they
were sorry yesterday she did it Ellie
she plays a lot like Joseph's you know
she has a pistol as one shot which is
great I think I guess that point of the
game is them wanting to show us how
powerful Abby is she can take down this
huge monstrosity this huge resident evil
monstrosity is actually there's a point
resident five like Chris Redfield just
punches a huge boulder it's just like
look how powerful Chris Redfield is and
your head this is this is Abby's moment
hulking you out and going to 9,000 and I
was gonna save like I at first I was I I
wish she just ran through that area like
you son just ran away from it but then
like after hearing you say that it's
like I guess it does kind of make more
sense for Abby's character to be like
all right I'm just gonna square up with
this thing I'm not gonna try to run from
it which I appreciate but I don't think
it makes up for the fact that that
bossfights not very fun and especially I
was playing on Survivor and I was like
banging my head against the wall because
it was like I was waiting for supplies
to respawn because I just simply didn't
have enough and like it would rush me
and I'd die instantly like I just
couldn't act in times frustrating yeah
the fact that supplies can respawn in
that section at all it just doesn't make
any sense it's so at odds with the rest
of the game and I think it's pretty well
established that that Abby is extremely
strong like like you don't see female
characters with that body type in
video games ever unless it's like a
fighting game and that woman is wearing
like panties though so like it doesn't
it's not the same and like the first
time you see her she's wearing this
tight Henley that like shows her muscles
and the when when you first play her at
the beginning of the game she's feeding
infected to death with her fists so I
think it's very well-established I mean
unlike Ellie she doesn't have a knife
right she has shins which were all like
SHIVs no but she can choke people out
and Ellie can't do that and so like
there is that distinction so like yeah
that but I was so that was when I turned
like that was the only time in the game
where I got so frustrated that I yelled
the TV I [ __ ] hate this last time we
talked I said like I there because I
started that boss fight at like 11:30 at
night and after like an hour and a half
of just playing it over and over again I
just looked at my phone I'm like I
wonder if Jake Phil or Callie like is
still awake because I want to text
someone and ask like maybe I'm doing
something wrong because the battlefields
not telling me how I'm supposed to be
fighting this boss and maybe I'm just
stupid and I can't figure out like
what's supposed to have stupid so now
let's bring it back to that face that
first face off against Ellie and Abbey
in the theater how did that make you
guys feel because I for one was
definitely that was such a weird scene
because it's like I don't want to kill
Ellie but I'm also pissed at Ellie but
also like can't we just all not fight
with a persuade button he was terrified
I was so worried I mean I said in my
review that like by the time I got to
the end of Abby's section I was more
concerned with Abby's safety I was more
attached to Abby than I was to Ellie and
it's because of you know and yes
especially Dena safety I love Dena we
don't have time to like talk about her
too much I maybe I'll talk about a
little bit but like so I I wanted I
didn't want Abby to die
and I didn't want to kill Ellie and I
was just the whole time I was like
there's gotta be another way I can't do
this graze that I don't want Abby to die
and I don't want to kill through the
record one of the leaks that got out was
that Abby kills Ellie which as we know
and if you're watching this does not
happen there is more to it after that
there's actually quite a bit of the game
to it after that but I think that is
also like a very pivotal moment where
Abby doesn't kill Ellie even though
she's about to and it's partly because
life is like what are you doing
and like that that's the moment where
she's just like I gotta stop this and
she just like I don't wanna see you
again in walks out and that scene was
like such a release I guess because it's
like I was so tense I was like I don't
want anyone to die I and I was like at
least dead like that's that's all I can
see happening here and when that
happened it was just like a huge sigh of
relief that bit that sorry that bit
where she's got dinner in a chokehold
and she's back to her throat like she's
pregnant that's good you know yeah crazy
[ __ ] insane yeah it yeah I I mean I I
was still sad about Jessie I was sad
about Jessie the whole time I was just
like Jessie but love really is Abby's
moral compass and like you said Jake
liked her saving love and Yara and going
back to help them is really what it's
where it changed for you like where your
perspective shifted and love is really
such a good character because he he has
a perfective that nobody else in the
game has and for being a Sara fight and
for Abby that meant actually finding her
a way to redeem herself so I did I did
think it made a lot of sense when that
happened but the thing about it is I
don't I I knew it had to continue
because I knew it couldn't end there but
I was like Ellie
you killed a pregnant woman not even
like like that baby was about to come
out like a pregnant
woman and she was like shell-shocked
afterwards and like the sound cuts out
and stuff and then and she's like don't
kill my pregnant girlfriend and then but
like it's that that's not where she's
like I should never kill again she's
like well better Qi which I mean the
game does keep going then there's a
scene at the farm house which we talked
about earlier where Ellie is still kind
of getting flashbacks and like PTSD from
Joel's death and Tommy shows up and it's
like hey I found her she's in Santa
Barbara and then like even though I the
way Tommy Tommy is alive which is crazy
because he gets shot in the knee and
then shot I guess very close to the face
maybe like Gray's di or something cuz I
thought I'd be dead for Sherman and like
the post-apocalypse survived long enough
to get medical treatment yeah I mean all
they needed is alcohol in a rag and they
wrap it around like without a horse how
did Ellie mesh get a severely sick Dina
and annex severely injured Tommy back to
Jackson Wyoming
no horse and then they get back like
they're still infected around there's
probably other human survivors they had
to contend with and I'm like there's a
whole nother like section of game that
they just had to gloss over to see the
30-hour DLC just like Left Behind let me
deal see you are they feeling like
everyone be like this is a big flat hole
and they're like well tell her we got
DLC then it'll be nice photo booth you
can get a photo of all of them together
[Laughter]
but yeah I mean I think I kind of know
how everyone feels but like right when
you get to Santa Barbara like that was
that was for sure if you weren't if you
were still on board with Ellie's journey
up to this point when she gets to Santa
Barbara if you're still on board with it
I don't know I don't know how you still
playing the guy I cannot fathom No
yeah yeah the life is so perfect she's
got a good haircut now it's got a great
haircut she lives in a farmhouse
I just can't emphasize enough how much
of a dream that is for me she lives in a
farmhouse with her girlfriend and their
their baby she's a family she like they
have sheep they all sorts of [ __ ] and
it's sunset and it's all beautiful and
it's like of course it can't end here
because it's happy now but that's when I
was like are you [ __ ] kidding me and
that's what I mean about like that
that's it's not just about the revenge
for her because she did in a sense get
revenge on Abby already she's killed
everybody that out that Abby cares about
except for Liv and she doesn't know who
love is so that doesn't matter it this
Santa Barbara trip is only there because
she needs to have a memory of Joel that
is not him getting his face beaten and
she needs to forgive him for everything
he's done and that's I was really angry
with her leaving Dina and going to Santa
Barbara and like I said it took me
several days to like get that
perspective and that's that is what I
think the rationale for the Santa
Barbara section is is that that parts
about forgiveness and not revenge you
can say I guess a way to rephrase this
would be not how does it make you feel
but do you think it makes sense do you
think her decision to go to Santa
Barbara now that you sat with it a
little bit like makes sense does that
seem rational and I know like kind of
note because she had a perfect life but
at the same time given Ellie's character
up until this point like were you able
to buy that I can I don't like it but I
can buy the decision for Ellie to go to
Santa Barbara I don't like the decision
that she made but I can buy into why she
does what she does I did find it rather
interesting that they they do flash
between both Abby and Ellie for the
Santa Barbara section but they flash
over in a way where you skip whatever
must have occurred with Abby that she
goes from threatening le that she would
kill her the next time she sees her to
that the next time they actually do meet
face to face
Abby is just like look I just want to
pack it up and go home and let go our
separate ways like we don't have to do
this it's Ellie that has to instigate
the fight and so we never finally see
that like final forgiveness where Ellie
like the game has to basically trick us
into thinking that both women are still
angry at one another all the way up to
them meeting each other again well yeah
I mean I kind of think I didn't think
Abby was angry with Ellie at that point
I just thought she was so beaten and
bloodied and like just didn't care she
was like I like if there's no way I can
fight right now I don't want to fight
like this is all like I'm sure she was
feeling better I'm sure she would have
been ready to throw down with Ellie but
I kind of just got the impression that
she was very much like I can't do this
right now
I was not feeling better yeah Crucified
vote god knows how long that's not like
if she wasn't in that situation I feel
like maybe she would've been more ready
to fight but because she was like dying
she was like no and you know she has she
has left to care about now as well yeah
she has her own little Ellie to take
care of yeah yeah it's so much little
Ellie it's so much more about love like
they're both dying right they've been
tortured I think they were in the
Rattler prison camp for what two months
before Ellie shows up I think that's
when a character says yeah yeah so like
like she's been broken probably by these
slave trader people so III think there
was enough that we didn't need to see
that I I did kind of get it and I do
think that love had that that the fact
that love was the one to be like Abby
don't at the end of the like theater
sequence does help bridge that gap but
yeah I wish I had sing a little bit of a
little bit more of a be in Santa Barbara
but um I I do like that you say it's
a little le and because I do think
eventually Abbi becomes a joel foil more
than a Nelly file at that tail end that
is further context like I just want to
protect this kid that's all I have and I
I do like the way that's flipped on its
head a little bit um yeah yeah I mean
that leads up to the final fight which
is brutal le threatens to kill Liv if
Abby doesn't fight her and then you have
this pretty intense fight that's just
like I don't know there's two women who
are like beaten and bruised and dying
like trying their best to kill each
other but not I don't know it's it's
tough to play it's another scene that I
found very tough to play it's so bloody
like yeah the fact that cut marks only
appear on Abby as you slice like in
those plays it's like it's not like this
random thing where oh you've done enough
damage to Abby she's starting to look
and you're just like no we're gonna show
you the consequences of your action
something that we've spared you from
because most of the horrific deaths
before this have been in cut scenes but
now you're actually going to go through
the process of essentially beating
someone to death which was a horrific
experience to go through even in just a
video game setting yeah and like by that
point we're all like Ellie don't do it
so like to be playing to be playing
Ellie in that moment it's it's
interesting cuz you've already been a be
in that moment at a much at the peak of
their like you know hating each other
yeah their beef but to be Ellie in that
moment to be like no after everything
we've been through you can't do this
made that all the more difficult to do
and this was another thing that I didn't
fully understand until I thought about
the game for like a week which was why
she why Ellie stops because she stops
like right about when Abby bites her
fingers off
and she has browning heavy right yeah
yeah she's like she a bee he's bitten
her fingers off and she's drowning her
and she has this flash of joel playing
guitar and that's the first memory we
see of Joel in a while that's not him
getting his face beaten in and so it
took me like a week to be like oh that's
when she forgave that's when she was
done and I don't think you fully get the
effect of that until she goes back to
the farmhouse and tries to play guitar
and can't and it's like oh she's
realized that she really has lost
everything but by now including the the
good the good things about Joel the gift
that Joel gave to her yeah sir there's a
rough buddy yeah seriously one of the
few things that one of the few positive
memories was them was him teaching her
guitar she can't do it anymore
and like there's even that line on the
at the farmhouse where she has JJ on the
tractor and she's like when you're not
pooping yourself anymore I'm gonna teach
you how to play a guitar and like
playing it a second time that definitely
hit a lot harder than it did the first
time obviously cuz I didn't know what
was gonna happen but man I think like
just in general like the second
playthrough I enjoyed a lot more it was
still brutal and tough to get through
but just with all that contact context
and knowing what the what the pacing and
plot was gonna be like it was much
easier for me to appreciate the game as
a whole I think I do want to talk a
little bit about the Sarah fights as a
group because I think when the last time
we recorded this I think Jordan brought
up a really good point and I I'm
thinking of it of this because of Lev
and I did want to talk about loves
character and about how being a trans
boy I think that was handled really well
by the game I think I really like the
scene where you hear somebody dead named
him and he says to Abby did you hear
what they called me and Abby says yes
and he says do you want to ask me about
it and Abby says do you want me to ask
you about it and he says no and that's
just dropped Abby never presses it again
I was like wow Abby's pretty woke for
somebody who's
in the military apocalypse but and I
think that you know for all of the
vilifications that the Sara fights gets
throughout the game you really see the
like loves loves community is very
intolerant of this aspect of him but he
has a lot of wisdom with regard to other
things and I the thing that really got
me was fighting the Sara fights at the
end of Abby's section where I was like
whoa weird this is a lot and I am just
killing people left and right and and
that's what I meant when I talked about
violence going unexamined is that a lot
of those people even though they have
names and they cry out when you kill
their friends and all of that there's
not really consequences for those people
dying like their families don't come and
try to kill you
you know they there's no there's nothing
to stress that it's especially weird in
that moment because at that point in the
game as a be like she has you know more
or less redeemed herself and you kind of
don't want to keep mindlessly killing as
a B and the game not to let you just
leave it be like have the option to just
leave it be and just ghost them or
whatever is is a bit strange in this is
something we talked about with just the
factions in general and justifying the
violence and you know WLF gets the
benefit of having the other side of the
story told that then there's a whole
section with the sarah fights which
doesn't really get the same treatment
then you have the rattlesnakes the
Rattlers sorry you would just like
outright bag slave is and you have
nothing else going for them at all which
yeah so it kind of drops the ball in
that sense for sure the Rattlers were
like just so evil like they're like yeah
we capture infected and chain them up
and like treat them as animals and then
and like we lock people up in cages and
don't feed them and if they do one bad
thing we hang them on a post and
it was only affected them - yeah if you
try to escape again I'm going to like
send you into a room with that effect
I'm like that's really [ __ ] up man
even though the game may not be as
successful in humanizing the sera fights
as it does the WUF it at least tries
well we think the Rattler's it's just
like yeah they're here they're just
there in your way so you can get there
here just so they can have captured a be
and so you could kill these people to
get to a B yeah they're much more a
device than anything else and I I do
think and I want to be able to hear
Jordan's point again about the seraphic
yes we get to Jordan but the last thing
I want to say is that my issue is more
kind of to Ed's point about like there's
no it doesn't really fit Abbie's
character development at that point for
her to be killing so much so late in in
her section so day three was when I was
kind of like I wish I had I wish I could
just kind of escape instead of getting
into fights I don't know why there has
to be combat here because it it it fits
the story that it makes sense that the W
Olaf is planning this this attack to
coincide with the storm but it just
doesn't quite mesh with Abby's
characterization and that was my issue
and that was one of the bigger missteps
but yes
take it away Jordan okay sorry I just I
I'm sure people are gonna find ways to
get through those sections without
killing it people and be like oh you
guys are wrong you can do without it
because I think two more in fact is
gonna try to do a like don't kill anyone
encourage the game encourages it but
like for me personally playing on a
harder difficulty like a lot of those
combat situation situations I only
killed the people who are like directly
in my way and I know your review you
made a point that like if there's all
these collectibles that encourage you to
kill people so you can loot them but
like from my point of view from my
experience like I wasn't just like
alright we're gonna like stack up the
bodies here it was like there's two
people that are in my way to get to this
horse so I'm gonna kill them and just
run because that's all I have the amp
that's all I can afford to do right now
yeah that's true
god bless you Callie
reminding us of all these points that we
made and I just had completely forgotten
that I had made that conversation so
thank you for having a much better
memory than me but I think a huge part
of why I like a B section a lot more
than le section is that we get to go
through the transformation that ABI has
with her whereas le story is kind of
like mix mesh there's a lot of like
bouncing back and forth and timeline we
don't really know what you know so our
growth with her is kind of splintered
but with Abby we kind of get this
introduction we're after playing as le
and we've killed these people that we've
only just referred to as scars up to
this point and they're like Oh scars the
bad guys the wolves don't like scars and
like I can get on board with this I've
encountered them several times and
they've attacked me the very first
chance that I saw them so yeah let's
let's [ __ ] them up let's go after them
let's kill them and so you're on board
with everyone in the wolf community just
kind of bad-mouthing the scars even
though they're not called the scars
you've picked up plenty of notes prior
to that saying that they're called the
Sarah fights but since they scar their
face you just keep calling them scars
and then you kind of have this moment of
realization that they are more than just
this negative stereotype that you've had
of them when you actually get to meet
two of them in person and get to know
their culture and kind of find out this
blatantly Christian like origin that
they have and their society and their
culture and you realize that they're
more than just a few violent ones that
you've encountered and there's this
awesome line from love where he's like
oh yeah we have all these rules about
peace and stuff like that and I was like
well why do all the people attack I was
like those soldiers don't have to follow
the rules and it's this kind of
eye-opening moment for Abby where she
realizes that she's been prejudiced
against the Seraph lights this entire
time and LED has to constantly keep
reminding her to refer to them as that
and you as the player realized that you
have also been persecuting against this
people and that you have also been this
kind of [ __ ] typing just killing them
whenever they show up and so you kind of
go through that transformation with a B
and you go through that Redemption arc
so to speak with a B and it feels a
little bit more real and feels a little
bit more powerful and I will say for
that moment where you do go for the
Sarah fights island I had a different
interpretation of it in the sense that
when you first get there there's this
moment of like a lot of stealth or just
trying to get through the village that
you can get to Lev and bring him home
and it's significantly easier to get
through that portion of the story
without the killing field area yeah like
that but like it's it's much easier to
get through that and then it's only
after that you have that encounter with
the wolves and Abby
kind of has to pick a side and be like
no Lev is my people that for me I'm like
Lev is my people too and even though I
don't want to kill the people in my way
I will kill all the people in my way to
make sure that this pure boy can get off
of this island and it's one of the few
moments in the game where kind of a key
as you said Kelly the game tries to make
you kind of humanized these characters
by giving them names and doesn't really
work but it was the first moment where I
was like I don't really want to kill all
the sera fights in my way I don't want
to really kill the wolves in my way but
I am going to do it because I want to
get through this so it was actually for
me like the first point in the game
where what lasts of us party was trying
to do like actually worked for me
mm-hmm yeah I think one of the points
that I really like that you brought up
is it's very well established that
they're called sera fights you've been
picking up notes for hours where they
refer to themselves as sera fights and
you can like go to their shrines like
kind of felt weird picking up the notes
from the shrines like I should probably
leave that there but yeah right and yeah
the fact that Ellie's backpack is
unzipped and condemned is like
everything
there's soap it stresses me out um but I
remember texting Jake something like oh
I'm in the scar section like you you you
as the player are kind of trained to
dislike them I disliked them for a while
because I was like cult [ __ ] in an
apocalypse is hokey and I don't like it
um but I do think that that feeling went
away from me for sure but you're kind of
predisposed to dislike them and hearing
love assert like no Sarah fights that is
what we're called fits so well with his
character too because his character is
about asserting his identity so I think
there's a lot of good with the Sarah
fights and through Levin Yared they
become humanized yeah I think my bigger
issue with the the violence against like
in regular combat scenarios is just that
there's this whole theme of like cycles
of violence and consequence but these
people aren't significant enough to
provide big consequences so it just kind
of felt like what the game was trying to
do didn't hit for me for a lot of that
but I think the story is is and like the
the characters are so good and make that
very worthwhile to me anyway um I was
gonna say one more thing about either
live or the Seraph I don't remember oh I
just wanted to say to hit Jake's point
about the collectables I did feel it
wasn't just collectibles it was also
loot and part of that is just me being a
player that I want to have as much loot
as possible I want to pick up everything
that really did incentivize me to kill
everybody in an area just because it's
much safer to loot when they are dead
and I was playing on hard so it wasn't
like you know like it was super easy to
do or anything but yeah
I I just found that to slow my pace a
lot night I became very irritated with
the looting and eventually I'm looking
forward to replaying this game after I
have all the collectables and I don't
care to look for the collectables and I
can just play how I want to play every
combat encounter gonna find crafting
materials and submachine gun MMO and all
that kind of stuff which is a bummer
although because there are so many
difficulty and accessibility options you
can tweak the difficulty and have like
super high resources and then make the
combat heart so you could play a Hard
difficulty and I'd be like well I'd have
to loot as much because I turned up the
resource pickups so you could do that
which i think is really cool
and I also think one thing we should
note is that the collectables are worth
getting like especially the notes I
really like the world-building in those
notes and so it's not a matter of like
we're just obsessive trying to get the
plat and like that's why we're getting
the collectables I think there is an
incentive to get them and that's what I
mean about the video game II aspects not
always gelling with the story yeah
totally I mean even like you pointed out
in your review how it's like seems so
trivial that Ellie's trying to find
trading cards throughout this but like
even those I still enjoyed collecting
and reading like this stuff about him
even though yeah I totally agree with
you and it's like why does Ellie care
like why would I like care about this
right now but you know I still cared and
I'd still kill an entire group of people
just so I could you know poke my head
around try to find a dumb card but
anyway we've been going on for quite a
while but before we end do you guys have
any closing remarks anything you want to
add all of the Asian characters in this
game appeal imperfect I wish we eat a
girl had gotten an actual name other
than just did why is she just called
betta girl in the credits because
there's a conversation that you can have
if there is a B and she's like hey
Whitney what's up and like the credits
just beat a girl being prejudiced
against Vita owners my final statement
is very similar to n but I think all the
women are fantastic characters I they're
not pairing perfect but I really love it
when female characters are allowed to be
complete shitheels
I love a bad person who's a woman you
don't you don't always get that it's
it's hard to explain but the best
something I really like to see is just
really complicated women the body types
a plus you got body hair you don't see
that ever and the by woman was handled
beautifully
I just thought all of the the
characterization of all those people was
fantastic Jordin anything you add I just
kind of like to reiterate something that
like Kelly quickly said please look for
all of the notes like the notes the side
stories in this game are as good if not
better than the ones in the original
Last of Us and a lot of them kind of tie
into the overall theme of violence
begets violence in some sort of way and
it just makes for a much better
experience if you like actually are
going through a small town and you find
out why it's been abandoned and everyone
is dead and some people are locked in a
back closet like space please do it
it'll make the game so much better it is
worth it it's worth it even if it's
annoying sometimes it's almost as if
they like took that ish scene or that
ish collectibles from the first game I'm
gonna try to do that in every single
area you went to very rarely did were
any of those stories like unsatisfying
unless I missed a note and had to go
back and find it later
so yeah it's definitely worth looking
out for those things so you know you
still might want to kill everyone just
so you get those because they are pretty
good I guess the only thing I have to
say is that I think if you played
through it and you're willing to do it
again I think you should play through it
again because I think there's a lot more
you can get out of a second playthrough
and it adds a lot of context and overall
I mean while I was more I guess engaged
with my first playthrough like I was
more like excited to see what would
happen next
I appreciate the game a lot more having
played it twice but I think that's
that's it we good good
all right well that's been GameSpot
spoiler discussion of the last of his
part to make sure to check out one of
Callie's reviews either her spoiler
review well actually I guess if you're
listening to this and you made it this
far
just watch the spoiler review that makes
a lot more sense but we have a bunch of
lastest coverage that you should check
out we're also in the middle of play
four also there's a bunch of interviews
live streams in a bunch of different
conferences and whatnot that we're
covering so you're gonna want to make
sure to stay tuned the game spot to
check all that stuff out and we'll see
you next time
[Music]
I don't know I'm to say days and you
shine
[Music]
Martin's but a beast
[Music]
save
[Music]
you
[Music]